hi I'm Kevin Jenkins president and CEO
of world vision international today i'm
answering a question from elaine looters
yes please tell us what you care about
what future direction you seek and how
you will contribute to improving the
state of the world I you know a few
months ago I was in Haiti and I met a
young mother just had a child name was
romita she was thanking me for all the
ways a World Vision had helped her and
her newborn baby after the earthquake
and after thanking me she said you know
but I don't I don't want to always
depend on aid on charities on NGOs I
want to work I want a job I want the
dignity of providing for my family
myself I that's what I that's how I want
to see the world change how I the hopes
of romita to to have the dignity of work
in a country where unemployment is sixty
percent and to provide for her child and
all the hopes and aspirations she has
for that child would become a reality
you know poverty property is not really
generally about money it's about
relationships a relationship with
oneself we're over time one becomes have
a sense of powerlessness that you're in
your opinion doesn't count a
relationship with one's community you
you you try to get things done some
people don't even have a birth
certificate don't even identity in
society that helps them go to a health
clinic so it's a relationship with your
community and and that so these
relationships in a community like the
Facebook community if we could together
you know all from all over the world not
because governments are generating it
but because each of us cares in this
global village we work we live in that
just because you're lucky enough to be
born in Europe or the United States or
Australia or Canada any other country
where everything was set up for you so
many kids go to bed hungry every night
so many kids mother's dream for them
things that are not possible unless we
all get engaged so find your passion
take your time talent and treasure and
get it in behind that passion and we can
change the world together thank you